bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre dans
filcho l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale tout de
suite on passe au titre de cette
édition le projet de la ZAC la zone
d'aménagement concerté char Charles
renard enfin lancée la ville de
saint-ciier l'école y travaille depuis
10 ans la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie des yvines a rendu un
diagnostic public peu réjouissant du
département seule nouveauté les
discussion autour de l'aéroport de
toussu le noble enfin immobilier
d'entreprise un secteur plus que jamais
d'actualité pour l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline ce mardi acteur
économique et dirigeant de la communauté
d'agglomération étit présent pour
évoquer les projets futurs et puis nous
parlerons des 10 ans de Créactive une
association ililinoise qui accompagne et
fédère des femmes chefs d'entreprise et
porteuse de projet nous retrouvons Chloé
Duval bonjour vous êtes membre de
l'association et également entrepreneuse
nous ferons donc avec vous un bilan de
de l'action de l'association Créactive
et nous évoquerons également la
situation et les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer les femmes à la tête
d'entreprise mais avant cela place aux
informations économiques de la
semaine à saincir l'école l'ancienne
caserne militaire Charles ren laisse
place à un nouveau quartier le projet
vient d'être lancé il accueillera de
nouveaux logements des bureaux des
commerces de proximité une crèche ou
encore un groupement scolaire la
première pierre a été posée ce matin
yolen Torz et Elodie moine étaient
présentes c'est le jourg à sinir l'école
les chantiers des premiers logements du
quartier Charles renard ont démarré avec
la pose de cette première pierre par le
maire de la commune ancienne caserne
militaire le quartier est maintenant
prêt à accueillir 1450 logements des
équipement public ainsi que des
aménagements paysagés on va ainsi
pouvoir réunir l'est et l'ouest de
saint-sy qui été coupé par à la fois
cette base aérienne et l'école militaire
en ce qui concerne les logements une
cinquantaine destiné aux actifs se
verront cofinancés à partir d'épargne
privé une solution innovante qui
s'appuie sur la technique de
démembrement de propriété et inventé par
une société parisienne ça revient à
acheter un bien ce que nous faisons puis
nous vendons mur à un épargnant qui
pendant une durée de 15 ans ne ne reçoit
pas son bien ou en tout cas ne n'a pas
la pleine propriété de son bien et nous
vendons l'usufruit c'est-à-dire l'usage
du bien à un bailleur qui en
l'occurrence sur ces programmes est
immobilièr 3F qui lui cherche des
locataires attribu les logements et
s'occupe de l'entretien du bien 15 ans
plus tard le le la pleine propriété
reconstitué et l'épargnant bénéficie de
la pleine jouissance de son bien autre
volet du projet dans la zone Nord près
de l'aérodrome la création de la
première zone d'activité et de bureau de
la ville c'est de l'emploi c'est changer
un peu l'image de la ville qui était
essentiellement une ville d'ortoire pour
enfin avoir des emplois sur place les
premier logement devrait être livré pour
2016 et le quartier achevé en
2021 vendredi la Chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de Versailles a rendu
publique une analyse économique sur le
département le bilan de ce agnostic
n'est pas très réjouissant le taux de
chômage est en hausse
l'industrialisation a baissé de 19 %
depuis 2002 et si 7100 emplois ont été
créé depuis 2000 7000 ont été détruits à
la suite de ce bilan la CCI a annoncé
qu'elle allait se focaliser sur
plusieurs grands taxes un des plus
importants est l'accompagnement des
filières historiques en reconstruction
et des filières émergentes comme le
développement durable le médical ou
encore le numérique seul nouveauté
l'aérodrome de tousul noble qui a été
évoqué et reste en projet une étude
récente a été réalisé sur l'intérêt d'un
éventuel développement de l'aviation
d'affaires sur le site et aussi de son
impact sur l'attractivité du territoire
je vous propose d'écouter les précisions
du président de la CCI Gérard
bachelier une étude commune qui fait
l'état de l'ensemble de
l'offre aéroportuaire dans
l'île-de-fance et de l'intérêt éventuel
de développer une activité industrielle
autour de toussu lié par exemple à à à
l'avion électrique mais aussi d'autres
activit
et de voir comment justement cet
aéroport peut aider au développement
économique du territoire les magasins
Fly de Sartrouville les coignères ont
été liquidées les six salariés du
magasin d'Orgeval sont également menacés
ils ont fait grève pour protester contre
leur situation ils devront attendre
jusqu'au 7 octobre pour savoir si une
offre de reprise a été reformulée le
groupe mobilier européen détenteur des
ancien des enseigne pardon fly Atlas et
croatier est en grande difficulté il a
perdu près de 20 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en 2013 sur toute la
France 850 emplois sont menacés et 44
magasins risquent la
fermeture l'immobilier d'entreprise est
un secteur très dynamique à
Saint-Quentin il a qui accueille
d'ailleurs le territoire accueille plus
de 7000 sièges sièges sociaux pardon
mardi une matinée d'échange sur le thème
de l'immobilier d'entreprise a eu lieu à
montiné- le Bretonneux de nombreux
acteurs économiques étaient présent au
siège social de Mercedes l'objectif
était de présenter les nouveaux projets
d'avenir également de dresser un bilan
de de de l'attractivité du territoire
qui est je vous le rappelle le deuxième
pôle économique de l'ouest francilien
des images de William l Pascal Joseph au
montage comme un symbole de
l'attractivité de l'agglomération le
bâtiment star Center à Montini le
Bretonneux inauguré il y a à peine 1 an
Mercedes-Benz a choisi ce site pour la
situation économique du bassin de
Saint-Quentin et sa proximité avec Paris
avec 9300 établissements économiques et
3,8 millions de mètres carrés d'immob
d'entreprise le territoire est attractif
nous avons vraiment développé les
services aux salariés les restaurants
d'entreprise les crèche interentreprise
les hôtels également qui est une une
particularité importante pour les
entreprises on a une offre sur
Saint-Quentin qui permet à une
entreprise de répondre à une demande de
80 m² jusqu'à 65000 m² malgré la crise
la croissance du parc immobilier de
50tin est stable en 2013 elle atteint le
palier du million de mètres carrés après
une forte diminution en 2009 sur
l'Île-deFrance les tendances ont changé
les produits livrés clés en main sont
beaucoup plus demandés les mises en
chantier diminuent 600000 m carré en
2013 contre une moyenne annuelle de 1
million de mè Carr entre 1997 et 2008 le
marché d'investisseurs s'est transformé
en marché d'utilisateur c'est beaucoup
par le renouvellement immobilier donc
démolition reconstruction que l'offre
immobilière sur 51 va continuer à être
produite et bien sûr il y a pour une
part marginale de l'ordre de de 10 à 20
% de l'immobilier neuf sur des terrains
aujourd'hui vierges disponibles mais
cette cette offre sur l'immobilier
disponible encore non construit elle se
réduit puisque aujourd'hui le le le
territoire se se continue à à à
s'aménager se restructurer de grands
projets sont prévus sur l'agglomération
comme l'extension du campus du Crédit
Agricole à l'horizon 2016 le nouveau
bâtiment Alsace avec ses 20000 m carré
pourra accueillir 5000 employés d'autres
projets sont en cours comme le Garden
West ou omegga Park des des paris osé
alors qu'en Île-de-France 3,9 million de
mètres carrés de bureaux sont vacants et
la tendance est à la modération des
constructions globalement Saint-Quentin
est plutôt une zone dans lequel il y a
une adéquation qui est assez réaliste
entre les projets et la demande donc on
peut se dire que globalement il n'y a
pas de suroffre à craindre où il n'y a
pas de décalage
important entre l'offre et la
demande y compris à horizon 2030 les
Yvelines concentrent 9 % du parc de
bureau de l'Île-de-France avec véisi le
pôle de Saint-Quentin et celui qui a le
mieux résisté à la crise il dispose
encore de 150000 m²
disponibles notre entretien de cette
semaine revient sur l'association
ivinoise Créactive nous recevons Chloé
Duval Chloé Duval bonjour euh vous êtes
entrepreneuse mais aussi membre de
l'association Créactive une association
qui fédère je le rappelle les femmes
chefs d'entreprise et porteuse de de
projet dans les ivelines elle faitte
également la semaine prochaine c'est ça
c'est 10 ans tout à fait alors tout
d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer un peu voilà quel est le but
de cette association et quelles sont ses
actions qu'est-ce qu'elle propose
finalement alors l'association elle est
née en 2003 à l'initiative de de
d'institutionnel de la région alors
exactement à l'initiative de la Maison
de l'Entreprise de sa an Yveline et du
Centre d'Information des droits de la
femme et de la famille euh et c'était
pour promouvoir l'entrepreneuriat au
féminin c'est devenu très vite une
association
indépendante qui existe donc maintenant
depuis 10 ans donc on en est très fier
et qui regroupe maintenant une
quarantaine de membres donc ce sont des
femmes qui sont soit chefs d'entreprise
déjà soit qui ont un projet le projet de
créer leur entreprise et qui se
rassemble essentiellement dans le but de
bah de trouver là un soutien un réseau
d'étaufer leur réseau de trouver des
informations et puis de faire du
business aussi même si c'est pas le
principal de de l'association alors
comment ça se passe vous vous réunissez
chaque semaine est-ce que vous organisez
des des alors chaque mois il y a une
soirée organisée autour d'un thème avec
un intervenant extérieur qui vient nous
parler de alors ça peut être toutes
sortes de thèmes qui sont en rapport
avec l'entrepreneuriat une Sam toujours
ah non pas du tout ces soirées sont
d'ailleurs ouvertes à tous on peut être
homme et y aller si le thème vous
intéresse euh par contre on pour pour
devenir membre il faut être femme voilà
mais les soirées sont bien sûr ouvertes
à tous donc une fois par mois on se
retrouve soit sur un thème soit
simplement une soirée networking oou
alors on fait comme ça se fait
aujourd'hui des tables rondes et en 2 3
minutes on fait un pitch on se présente
on échange les cartes et hop on tourne
et et on continue donc voilà typiquement
la la soirée networking il y a parfois
des sorties à l'extérieur pour aller
visiter des entreprises de la région euh
euh et ça vous apporte voilà pour
visiter des entreprises c'est pour vous
donner des idées pour aussi vous vous
lancez pour donner voilà c'est
exactement ça pour donner des idées pour
se nourrir bah quand on est à la tête
d'une activité on a besoin de de
s'inspirer d'autres gens d'échanger sur
des problématiques sur sur des questions
et souvent quand on va voir ce qui se
passe ailleurs B voilà on se nourrit on
a plus de on a voilà on a plus d'idées à
mettre en place
et quelque chose d'important aussi au
sein de Créactive donc c'est c'est
ce cet échange
networking et on fait un échange de
compétences également ça s'appelle les
expertises créactives euh sur des
périodes données les membres de CréActif
s'engagent à donner gratuitement aux
autres membres qui en ont besoin une
heure de leur expertise d'accord donc ça
peut être pourquoi je sais pas pour une
comptable ou on est par exemple on a une
experte des réseaux sociaux qui peut
venir répondre à vos questions et vous
dire ben voilà c'est quoi les grandes
lignes vous faire un un audit rapide he
il s'agit d'une heure on a une exper
comptable on a une spécialiste RH et
justement C ces femmes donc dans au sein
de l'association est-ce que c'est plutôt
des chefs d'entreprise à la tête de de
d'entreprise avec plusieurs plusieurs
salariés est-ce qu'elles sont plus
seules quel est un peu le profil on est
le profil il est clairement très petites
entreprises l'entreprise la plus
importante chez nous elle a C ou si
salariés donc voilà on est souvent seul
à deux ou voilà donc c'est dans dans ces
moment là que justement on a besoin
d'être en relation avec d'autres
personnes pour aussi s'épauler c'est ça
enfin ça donne vraiment l'occasion
d'échanger de d'agrandir son réseau ben
vous savez quand on est déjà seul et
qu'on a pas de salarié c'est oui on a
besoin d'échanger on a besoin de pas
seulement d'ailleurs pour échanger des
idées ou des problématiques c'est se
détendre avec des des des femmes qui
connaissent un peu les même les mêmes
situations que vous voilà c'est et puis
trouver toujours un apport de
l'extérieur parce que quand on reste
tout seul dans son ordinateur ou dans le
nez plongé dans son activité on se rend
compte très vite qu'on a besoin de de
Saer l'esprit en fait d'accord alors
mardi donc c'est la 4e édition des
Rencontres créactives c'est aussi bah
votre anniversaire donc vous disons
qu'est-ce qui va être organisé vous
allez je sais pas chercher à à peut-être
faire venir d'autres femmes dans votre
association alors les rencontres
créctives on les organise déjà depuis 4
ans maintenant c'est la 4e édition il
s'agit d'une journée euh qui d'une
journée de donc qui se passe à Promopole
à montinil Bretonneux et euh où sont
enchaîne les ateliers les workshops les
conférences et euh parallèlement à ça
les membres de Créactive présent enfin
cell qu'il souhaitent présentent leur
activité sur des stands donc comme un
mini salon euh et ce qu'on cherche à
faire oui c'est nous faire connaître
faire connaître les actions de de
Créactive faire connaître les membres et
puis aussi euh susciter des vocations
peut-être susciter des vocation on
aimerait bien et puis apporter quelque
chose simplement à la communauté
d'entrepreneurs de de la région
et pour spécialement vos vos 10 ans
justement vous m'avez dire un alors je
dois préciser aussi que l'édition de la
semaine prochaine donc c'est mardi 7
octobre à partir de 9h et le thème ce
sera l'innovation en entreprise et en
s'adressant plus particulièrement à des
TPE PME d'accord euh je je je vous coupe
pour passer à un autre un autre
sujet vraiment parce qu'en tant que en
tant que entrepreneuse vous savez que
cette semaine c'était enfin hier c'était
la journée des des femmes entreprene
eneur voilà qu'est-ce que vous ça vous
apporter Créactive et justement
qu'est-ce que vous conseilleriez à une
femme qui souhaite se lancer vous en
tant qu'avec votre expérience voilà
qu'est-ce que vous lui direz al moi ce
que ça m'a apporté
euh j'ai un cas particulier c'est-à-dire
que j'habite dans les ivelines je j'ai
un bureau qui est à Paris euh et je fais
du conseil et j'ai cherché un moyen de
d'élargir mon réseau dans les ivelines
autour de chez moi puisque après tout ça
me paraît malin de pouvoir travailler
pas trop loin de chez moi donc ce que
m'a apporté CréActif ce sont voilà c'est
un réseau un réseau
de de peut-être prestataire ou de
peut-être clients ou de prescripteurs
des gens qui me connaissent que je
connais donc si j'ai besoin de quelque
chose je sais à qui je peux demander
d'accord alors tout de suite vous pose
de passer à la question de la semaine
qui porte justement en fait sur la la
place des femmes et leur vision par
rapport au à l'entrepreneuriat donc nous
avons demandé à vous yvelinois voilà
pourquoi pourquoi selon vous il y a
encore si peu de femmes à la tête
d'entre
entreprise privilégie d'élever les
enfants avant avant de penser à la
carrière bah on laisse effectivement
peut-être moins la place à des femmes à
des postes de direction enfin moi dans
ma société la femme c'est enfin la
directrice c'est une femme il peuvent
favoriser d'abord la vie de famille
avant leur carrière chose qu'un homme
non il y a pas beaucoup de femmes qui
supportent certaines pressions et je
pense que les hommes en général hein je
dis supportent plus la pression que que
que les femmes bah c'est le matisme je
pense ils font pas confiance aux femmes
et pourtant on est des battantes et des
travailleuses je sais pas mais je pense
que les on leur laisse moins la chance
que les hommes c'est ça c'est dû au fait
qu'il y a des certaines personnes qui
sont pas prêts à changer leur façon de
de penser de voir les choses et qui
changeront jamais leur façon de penser
en fait peut-être avec la nouvelle
génération les gens seront plus ouverts
d'esprit je sais pas alors queal est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec ce que vous
venez de voir et d'entendre
euh ben je je oui je trouvais que les
gens qu'on a entendu là étent
relativement modéré il y a plein de
raisons pour laquelle les femmes se
lancent pas forcément dans
l'entrepreneuriat qu'elle supporte moins
la pression là j'en suis pas du tout sûr
je pense que une femme est aussi capable
qu'un homme de diriger une entreprise et
même des grosses entreprises enfin on a
suffisamment d'exemples je crois pour
savoir que que c'est comme ça alors
pourquoi après tout de mémoire je les
chiffres sur 170000 entreprises qui sont
créées c'était c'est des chiffres 12 il
y a quand même près de 40 % qui sont
créés par des femmes donc c'est pas si
mauvais que ça voilà c'est quand même
plutôt c'est pas si mauvais que ça je
pense que c'est culturel essentiellement
et que c'est vraiment en train de
changer d'accord et ben je vous remercie
que Duval je je je vous remercie de
venir sur notre plateau au revoir tout
de suite je vous propose de passer au
chiffres de la
semaine cette semaine il concerne
l'emploi intérimaire 6,8 c'est le
pourcentage d'emploi intérimaire en
moins dans les éelines par rapport au
mois d'août 2013 la baisse s'explique
par une croissance faible dans les
secteurs porteurs comme les transports
le commerce ou les services si la
tendance la tendance pardon dans ce
secteur est à la baisse la diminution
est moindre au niveau national 0,3 %. à
savoir que le mois d'août est atypique
pour le recours l'intérim et pas
toujours révélateur de la conjoncture à
venir à noté vendredi un grand forum de
recrutement a lieu à Paris place de la
Concorde 10000 offres d'emploi seront
proposées 500 entreprises des
collectivités locales et des organismes
de formation seront au rendez-vous
n'oubliez pas votre
CV l'entreprise de la semaine est une
petite entreprise de servicees innovant
à Versailles vadana Koo a monté sa
société redakimo orienté sur le conseil
juridique et notarial afin d'aiguiller
les acheteurs et les agences
immobilières et de leur faciliter les
démarches en amont d'une vente ou d'un
achat je vous propose de voir ces images
signées Elodie moan et au montage roman
rpini comme beaucoup de jeunes actifs
alex veut investir il aimerait bien
acheter à Toulouse la ville dont il est
originaire mais il n'est pas Essé de
trouver du temps et d'être au fait des
actualités de ce marché immobilier étant
à Paris c'est déjà une ville qui nous
prend beaucoup de temps et Don travail
et dans la vie personnelle alors si en
plus de ça il faut trouver du temps
euh pour trouver des appartements pour
monter des dossiers et parler avec des
agences trouver des courtiers
éventuellement ça prend encore plus de
temps avec l'évolution constante des
lois sur le logement difficil de s'y
retrouver surtout au moment complexe
c'est crucial de constituer son dossier
juriste en cabinet de notaire depuis
plus de 15 ans vadana Keo a décidé de
monter sa propre entreprise afin de
répondre à ce problème un manque
d'information souvent constaté au moment
de la signature d'un bien c'est qu'en
réunissant toutes les pièces qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a des problèmes
juridiques donc trop souvent j'arrive au
rendez-vous de signature et je
m'aperçoit donc qu'il y a des problèmes
juridiques qui auraient pu être vu et
résolus avant la signature tout
simplement sa société est née en avril
2014 elle propose des conseils notaria
juridiques et un accompagnement
administratif pour les particuliers et
les professionnels presque un service à
la personne une prestation novatrice
pour ce gérant de consergerie
d'entreprise propose au salariés de mes
entreprises clientes différents services
donc B basiquement tout ce qui est
pressing cordonnerie repassage des
Service à la Personne rechercher un
appartement rechercher la meilleure
solution pour un placement çaut prendre
du temps il faut aller faire des
consultations chez les fiscalistes chez
les agences immobilières et c'est vrai
que de pouvoir proposer ces services là
directement sur les lieux de travail
entre MIDH et 2 par exemple pendant la
la pause médiane ça permet de faire
gagner beaucoup de temps au salariés
vadana croix son entreprise elle perçoit
3 % en cas d'aboutissement du projet de
ses clients même si la société est jeune
elle espère à la fin de l'année arriver
à un chiffre d'affaires proche des 50000
€
notre zoom de la semaine est consacré au
métier de mécanicien un métier technique
qui tend à se spécialiser alors claire
Cambier et lodim moine sont allés dans
les evines à la à la rencontre de
mécaniciens en devenir et d'autres avec
un peu plus
d'expérience studieux Angelo et Raphaël
écoutent les conseils de leurs
formateurs technique cette année ils
préparent leur bac professionnel en
mécanique pour ouvrir son garage pas
besoin de formation mais mieux vaut être
armé pour répondre à la demande ce qui
seront diagnostiquer des véhicules qui
seront prendre des initiatives et qui
vont aller au-delà faire un ccup ou un
BTS ont plus de chance de trouver un
emploi dans un garage que un cap sur le
marché on trouve beaucoup de personnes
qui vont faire de la main de la
maintenance et c'est vrai que la
concurrence est importante avec un cap
les mécaniciens restent cantonnés à la
maintenance dans cette branche les
contrats à durée indéterminé ont laissé
place à l'intérim Angelo l'a bien
compris il envisage de poursuivre par un
BTS après l'obtention de son bac pro
mais ce passionné d'automobile et de
mécanique reste confiant dans son avenir
professionnel on aura toujours besoin
parce que en plus plus ça plus avec les
perfections de l'automobile plus ça va
devenir compliqué de réparer soême sa
voiture donc faut vraiment c'est pas
comme certains métiers qui se perdent
dans ce centre de formation une
cinquantaine de jeunes sont formés au
métier de mécanicien à la sortie de
l'école le salaire avoisinera les 1600 €
brut un chiffre en légère hausse donc en
dessous 18,4 c'est mauvais en dessous du
,4 c'est mauvais donc faudra que tu
mesures Angelo devrait trouver du
travail dans un garage ou dans une
grande firme automobile son but à terme
est d'être son propre patron plus de
responsabilité et de gestion
administrative pour un salaire plus
élevé de 2500 à 4500
€. autre garage autre ambiance à senscir
l'école Christian nérol a monté son
entreprise il y a 37 ans mécanicien
carrossier il a décidé de parier sur le
passé plutôt que sur les les nouvelles
technologies j'ai travaillé pendant 30
ans sur les voitures de l'époque enfin
récente et donc je me suis un petit peu
lassé et j'ai voulu retourner un petit
peu sur les mécaniques anciennes on est
plus en contact avec la technologie de
l'époque des années 1920 1930 il y a pas
d'électronique il y a pas d'électricité
Christian a pourtant eu une formation
traditionnelle 6 ans d'apprentissage
entre CFA et garage si il a choisi de
restaurer de vieilles voitures c'est une
question de
passion ah elle
tousse
voilà c'est au début des années 80 qu'il
s'est lancé dans ce secteur atypique une
niche très viable à l'époque mais depuis
quelques années son activité connaît une
diminution de 30 à 40 %. il faut savoir
que la voiture ancienne c'est un loisir
et dans un coup c'est le loisir qui
passe en dernier hein
l'automobile ça passe après les weekends
après le cinéma après les restaurants
les difficultés financières ne freineent
pas son enthousiasme il va régulièrement
et bénévolement faire de l'assistance
sur des rallyis dans le désert quand il
ne travaille pas sur ses voiture il en
possède neuf tout ancienne donc sur ce
véhicule 2000 he de restauration était
passé et depuis donc j'ai fait une
cinquantaine de m000 de kilomètres et
elle a servi également
au tournage de plusieurs films dans le
petit Nicolas le secteur de la mécanique
automobile très automatisé maintenant
est en perte de vitesse on compte près
d'une centaine d'offres d'emploi dans
les ilines les plus demandés sont les
mécaniciens spécialistes des véhicules
hybrides ou
électrique et si vous êtes plutôt fan de
voiturees dernier cri je vous rappelle
que le salon automobile a lieu porte de
versaill donc il commence ce samedi et
vous avez jusqu'au 19 octobre pour vous
y rendre maintenant place à Ling de la
semaine cette semaine de rendez-vous à
ne pas manquer c'est la deuxè édition du
Forum SOS rentrée l'occasion pour les
jeunes mais aussi souvent leurs parents
de se renseigner et de poser toutes les
questions sur l'emploi et les formations
possibles il se déroule le mardi 7
octobre de 14h à 18h à Versailles de
nombreux partenaires seront présents
comme le CIO de Versailles le centre
d'information et d'orientation de la
Chambre de Commerce de Paris ou encore
le dispositif jeune du conseil général
des ivelines passer un entretien
d'embauche n'est pas toujours évident et
souvent source de stress la compagnie
d'écp Théâtre propose un atelier gratuit
pour mieux communiquer en utilisant
justement les techniques du théâtre cet
atelier gratuit il se déroulera le jeudi
9 octobre à la Cité des Métiers à trrape
n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire merci de
nous avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous la semaine prochaine pour un
prochain numéro de filch je vous
souhaite une très bonne
soirée